[موسيقى]
حياكم الله رفض ابو بكر البغدادي امير ما
تعرف بدوله العراق والشام الاسلاميه
الدعوه المنسوبه الى زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري لحل تلك الدوله وقال
البغدادي ان الرساله المنسوبه الى الظواهر
تتضمن اخطاء شرعيه ومنهجيه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي اسباب وحيثيات الخلاف بين
زعيم تنظيم القاعده ومسؤول التنظيم في
بلاد
الرافدين وكيف سينعكس هذا الخلاف على
المستويين السوري والعراقي وعلى مستقبل
التنظيم بصوره
عامه
الخلاف الذي تفجر افقيا بين زعيمي فرعي
تنظيم القاعده في العراق وسوريا تحول في
اقل من شهرين الى خلاف راسي بين زعيمها
المركزي ايمن الظواهري وزعيم فرعها في
بلاد الرافدين ابو بكر البغدادي ففي واقعه
هي الاولى من نوعها رفض البغدادي صراحه
امر الظواهر القاطع بابطال ما يعرف بدوله
العراق والشام الاسلاميه التي اعلنها
البغدادي في ابريل الماضي ودمج بموجبها
فرعي التنظيم في العراق
وسوريا الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله بدا الاختلاف مستمرا ومتطورا
بين زعيم القاعده ايمن الظواهري وزعيم
تنظيم دوله العراق الاسلاميه ابو عمر
البغدادي الذي يتمرد حاليا على توجيهات
الظواهري امير القاعده التي حل بموجبها
تنظيم دوله العراق والشام الاسلاميه وكان
البغدادي قد انشا ذلك الكيان في ابريل
الماضي دون مباركه الظواهر ووحد فيه
تنظيمي دوله العراق الاسلاميه التي تنسب
اليه كثير من اعمال العنف والتفجيرات في
العراق وجبهه النصره التي تقاتل حاليا في
سوريا واثار القرار منذ اعلانه قلقا كبيرا
في اوساط جبهه النصره التي سارعت الى
التعريف عليه في بيان جددت خلاله ولاءها
للظواهري والقاعده واعلنت انه لم يتم
ابلاغها باي اندماج ما دفع الظواهري
لاصدار توجيهاته الاخيره ورفض البغدادي
توجيهات الظواهر واكد بقاء الدوله ودعا
عبر رساله بهذا الخصوص المقاتلين في
العراق وسوريا لمواصله العمل تحت رايتها
بل ذهب الى ابعد من ذلك واعتبر ان الرساله
المنسوبه للظواهري تحوي اخطاء شرعيه
ومنهجيه رساله زعيم تنظيم القاعده الاخيره
التي حل بموجبها كيان دوله العراق والشاب
الاسلاميه حملت كذلك لوما شديدا لزعيم
جبهه النصره ابو احمد الجولاني لرفضه قرار
الاندماج دون الرجوع اليه كزعيم للتنظيم
وامير لكل الجماعه باجنحتها المختلفه ولا
تكشف هذه التطورات عن خلاف فقط بين اجنحه
في القاعده انما تظهر ضعف التنسيق او
انعدامه بين قياده التنظيم واجنحه في
مختلف الجهات الساحه ملتهبه في العراق
وسوريا ونشاط جناحي القاعده في البلدين
مستمر وترى بعض الدوائر ان فكره توحيد
الجناحين في العراق وسوريا تحت اماره
واحده لم تلغى بل اجلت فقط بسبب التطورات
المتسارعه بشارعين السوري والعراقي
وافرازات ذلك على مختلف الصعود الامنيه
والسياسيه
وغيرها لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره منتصر الزيات المحامي والخبير في
شؤون الجماعات الاسلاميه من عمان معنا
محمد ابو رمان الباحث في مركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في الجامعه الاردنيه ابدا
معك منتصر الزيات عندما نتحدث عن القاعده
نحن بلا شك لا نتحدث عن مؤسسه او شركه
فيها لوائح تنظم الع العلاقه بين المدير
العام و مدراء الفروع
والاقسام العلاقه قائمه على الثقه واحترام
لل تراتب واي انتهاك لهذه التراتب لا شك
سيسبب ضرر كبير ما الذي يجعل زعيم فرع في
القاعده يجاهر بخلافه مع زعيم التنظيم هذا
هو السؤال منتصر
زيد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم هي من المسائل
المستحدثه زي ما اشرت لانه الدارج في
اوساط
الجهاديين ان مثل هذه المسائل لا تنقل الى
العلن وان مناقشه امور
تنظيميه لا تناقش عبر وسائل الاعلام ده
قصده واضح ودرجه عليه العمل في الجماعات
والتنظيمات
الجهاديه خروج هذا الموضوع الى العلن طبعا
لابد ان نفهمه في اطار
استثنائي زي ما حضرتك كنت بتشرحي دلوقتي
انه الظرف استثنائي
وال التواصل والاتصال بين القياده
المركزيه اللي القياده العامه بيمثلها
الدكتور ايمن الزواهري وبين القيادات
الفرعيه ليس من السهوله بمكان كما يظن
البعض
ف من وقت ما اعلن البغدادي القائد
البغدادي عن توحد
الدولتين
الاسلاميتفسير
اولا انه القائد الجولاني صمت صمت بعض
الوقت قبل ان يعلق وده فتح الباب
امام يعني همهمات في الداخل السوري او في
داخل النصره الامر الثاني البعض قال انه
وبعدين القائد الجولاني
طبعا نفى هذا بطريقه يعني توصف بانها
دبلوماسيه لكن البعض ايضا راى في قرار
التوحد انه بيفتح الباب ل النصيريين من
جهه ولامر من جهه اخرى انهم يشوش على
الجهاد الذي يقوم به السوريون وكل الفصائل
المجاهده ضد هذا
النظام فده اد لهم على طبق الصوره التي
تصور ان هناك يعني مرتزقه وان وان وان
كمان في حاجه ثانيه انه انه البعض بيقول
انه ما كانش في تشاور لما القائد
البغدادي صرح بهذا طبعا المتغير الجديد
هنا ان الدكتور الدكتور ايمن الزواهري
تدخل
ا تدخل هنا وامر او طلب ب يعني انهاء هذا
التوحد اللي يوصف انه كان من جانب واحد من
جانب القائد الميداني البغدادي الدكتور
ايمن الزواهري قال اتفضلي لا يعني يعني كل
هذه النقاط اللي تفضلت بشرحها يعني هي
معطيات ولكن في النهايه السؤال هو بعد ان
تدخل الظواهري بهذه الصوره جاء الرد من
البغدادي بهذه الصوره العلنيه وكان
بامكانه وربما هنا اوجه سؤال لمحمد ابو
رمان كان بامكانه ربما ان يشكك في مصداقيه
الرساله التي صدرت عن الظواهري يقول مثلا
يعني هي ربما ليست اكيد انها صادره عن
الظواهري هو اختار
المواجهه لماذا لم يكف عن نفسه حرج
المواجهه برايك
يعني يعني هذا صحيح اولا ما تحدث به
الاستاذ منتصر الزيات صحيح هنالك حاله
استثنائيه ظرف استثنائي في المشهد السوري
والعراقي
اي حيثيات صاحبت اعلان توحد دوله العراق
الاسلاميه وا الشام مع جبهه النصره
والردود التي حدثت بين الجولاني والبغدادي
ومن ثم تدخل الظواهري اعتقد انه بالرغم من
انه هذا حدث استثنائي الا انه الرساله
الجديده من قبل البغدادي تحمل في طياتها
شيء مستقبلي تحمل في طياتها اشارات
للمستقبل وهنالك رابط ما بينها وبين طبيعه
وخصوصيه العلاقه او التحولات التي حدثت في
الاونه الاخيره بين القاعده المركزيه وبين
فروع القاعده في العالم من المعروف انه
بعد 11 سبتمبر لم تعد قبضه القاعده
المركزيه كما كانت سابقا نحن نتحدث اليوم
عن جيل ثالث من القاعده نتحدث عن قيادات
جديده نتحدث عن تطور جديد القاعده اصبحت
رساله لامركزيه
وبالتالي العلاقه السابقه التي كانت فيها
نوع من الالزام الادبي ال الالزام السياسي
الاستراتيجي القياده الكاريزميه التي كان
يمثلها اسامه بن لادن وعطيه الله وغيرهم
التي ربما لا يحظى بها الظواهر بالمناسبه
مثل هذه التحولات هي انعكست اليوم على هذا
ال الخلاف العالمي الواضح غير المسبوق
داخل القاعده وانا اعتقد بالتاكيد له ما
بعده على مستوى علاقه القاعده بالفروع
وعلى مستوى
ايضا العلاقه بين دوله العرا او ما يحدث
في سوريا و اللافت اللافت يعني كلنا ندور
حول نقطه اذا سمحت لي اعود لمنتصر الزيات
هنا يعني الطريقه اللي تم فيها الرد سواء
من البغدادي او من الجولاني نفسه الجولاني
اختار ان يجدد البيعه للظواهري يعني وكانه
اراد ان او هكذا فهم يحول دفه الخلاف
من بين يعني مواجهه بينه وبين البغدادي
الى مواجهه بين البغدادي وزعيم التنظيم
المركزي وهذا ما حصل بالفعل نجح في ذلك
اليس
كذلك اه
بلى الحقيقه واضح جدا في انه الجولاني كان
بيعاني
وانه سطو كونو كونو في حقيقه الامر كان
يعمل ضمن
الاطار الروحي
والقيادي للبغدادي ده في حد ذاته حينما
انتقل الى النصره و
جانب الجهاد في
سوريا هيمن البغدادي او اراد البغدادي ان
يهيمن بطريقته على كل حال انا لا اريد ان
ادخل في
تفاصيل لكن الجولاني اراد برسالته تجديد
البيعه ا اعلان البيعه للدكتور ايمن
الظواهري في وقت فارق كان البعض يتحدث فيه
عن الرساله التي ارادها الجولاني في حقيقه
الامر حينما رفض او تنع او يعني قال انه
يرفض او يمتنع عن هذا التوحد ان لديه
شركاء في الثوره هذا المعنى الذي باح به
الجولاني وهو معنى له بالاهميه بمكان لانه
توسع النصره لم يكن بصفه اساسيه ورئيسيه
حسبما يرى الباحثون انها للمنشا الاعتقادي
العقائدي وانما للتوافق التوفق ق والسداد
في الرمي يعني النتائج التي حققتها النصره
في الميدان هو الذي جمع حولها فصائل كثيره
فحققت هذا هذا التفوق عند هذا الاختلاف هو
اراد ان يقول انه لم يختلف مع البغدادي في
المرجعيه وهنا رغم انه يتحدث عن الشراكه
مع شركاء الثوره الاخرين قال انه يبايع او
مازال على ولائه للدكتور ايمن الظواهري
فال المساله يعني كانه يحتمي به يعني
يحتمي به من المواجهه مع البغدادي هكذا
يعني قرت نعم نعم نعم لا باس وانا الحقيقه
اراهن على ان الحضور
الزعامة من الخبراء والمحللين لا اعرف اذا
كانوا يستندون على يعني فقط قراءه بين
السطور بعد ما حدث ام انها كانت قائمه بال
من قبل ان العلاقه بين الظواهري والبغدادي
اصلا لم تكن وثيقه وان الرجل البغدادي لم
يكن مقربا من الظواهري هل تعتقد ان هذا
العنصر الشخصي لعب دور في في هذا الخلاف
هنا ام هو ابعد
برايك انا في تقديري العنصر ليس الشخصي
طبيعه العلاقه التي كنت اتحدث عنها بين
قاعده العراق اصلا التي اسسها ابو مصعب
الزرقاوي ومن ثم بايعت القاعده المركزيه
وبين القاعده المركزيه لها خصوصيه كان
هنالك من يراجع الادبيات او الوثائق التي
كشفت بعد مقتل اسامه بن لادن يلحظ ان
هنالك ملاحظات كثيره للقاعده المركزيه على
ابو مصعب الزرقاوي وعلى سلوك قاعده العراق
كان هنالك اختلاف في التصور اختلاف في
تحديد الاولويات قاعده العراق
وترى الاولويات في قتال ايران الشيعه وهو
ما ظهر جليا اليوم في رساله البغداد عندما
دمج بين حزب الله والحكومه المالكي
والحكومه النصيريه والشيعه اذا الاولويه
تاتي في هذا المنطلق القاعده اولويتها
واضحه منذ اعلان الجبهه العالميه لمقاتله
اليهود
والصليبيين الاولويه لديها هي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اسرائيل هذه الحرب
الكونيه هي اولويه القاعده المركزيه ومن
يرجع الى الوثائق التي كشفت كان هنالك
ملاحظات كان هنالك عطيه الله يحاول ان
يقوم بدور لترشيد خطاب الزرقاوي لترشيد
دور قاعده العراق لكن كان وجود شخصيات
بتقديري مثل ك اسامه بن لادن الذي يتمتع
بكاريزما كبيره مثل عطيه الله مثل حتى ابو
مصعب الزرقاوي كان هنالك علاقه ما ساهمت
في اخ اخفاء وتخبئ مثل هذه الخلافات اليوم
نحن امام قيادات جديده برزت ال الفجوه
الاولويات على السطح وبرز الخلاف بشكل
كبير انا بتقديري رساله البغدادي خطورتها
هي صحيح هي رفض فقط ليس فقط لقرار ايمن
الظواهري انما في في في بعدها الاخر
والاهم اعاده هيكله العلاقه بين القاعده
المركزيه وبين فروع القاعده الاخرى في
المستقل وهذا هو بلب الموضوع اعاده
الهيكله هذه كيف ستنعكس
على جسد القاعده بشكل عام على واقع
ومستقبل التنظيم ارجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها الخلاف بين الظواهري والبغدادي
بشان ما يعرف بدوله العراق والشام
الاسلاميه منتصر الزيات عندما يقول
البغدادي الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق
والشام باقي ما دام فينا عرق ينبط او عين
تطرف لن نساوم عليها او نتنازل عنها حتى
يظهرها الله او نهلك دونها الرجل مستعد
بشكل كامل للقتال ولكن السؤال يقاتل
من
ال القرار اللي اصدره الدكتور ايمن
الزواهري لفض هذا
الخلاف يفتح الباب لامكانيه التداول فيه
الدكتور ايمن الزواهري لم ينهي الامر بشكل
حاسم لكنه قال تبقى الاماره المكانيه او
الاختصاص المكاني في العراق للبغدادي
ويبقى الاختصاص المكاني في الشام للجولاني
وقال ان هذا القرار لمده عام يسمح بتداول
والتشاور بينه وبين اخرين معنيين باصدار
القرار اذا اعتقد انه مع الوقت القريب
سيمكن تفادي هذا
المطب بهذا
التشاور الجولاني ومن معه في النصره يق
تلون عدوا
واضحا وهم منذ بداوا هذا العمل برعايه
البغدادي بالمناسبه والجولاني نفسه اقر
بذلك في التسجيل الصوتي الذي اصدره وقال
انه تلقى الدعم ودفع للعمل برعايه
البغدادي وانه امده بالمال وامده بالح
الوبه اجد صعوده في تقبل هذا المنطق سيد
منتصر زياد عندما نسمع شخص يقول يعني لن
نسا لن نتنازل حتى يظهرن الله يعني كانه
يتحدى يقول انا مستعد ان اذهب للنهايه في
هذا التحدي يعني لا اسمع لهجه التشاور او
نبره التشاور هذه التي تشير
اليها ما هو نبره التشاور دي هتظهر مع
الوقت اولا الدكتور ايمن الظواهري نفسه
طويل وباله طويل وادواته في الاتصال واسعه
لا يستطيع احد ان يقول اين الدكتور ايمن
الظهري دخيل
لا الدكتور ايمن الظهاري موجود في هذه
الاماكن منذ اواسط الثمانينات فهو خبرها
شبرا شبر وذراعا ذراع وهو داري على درايه
تامه بالقيادات الوسطى والكبرى وايضا على
درايه بالانتماء الاقليميه والانتماءات
الاقليميه التي احسب التي اشير اليها هي
التي بايعت القاعده بعد تفككها او بعد الض
الضربه القويه التي تلقتها اثر تفجيرات
نيويورك وواشنطن
2001 هي التي بادرت ولكن يبقى يبقى السؤال
يعني ربما يعني سامحني اذا كنت اريد ان
استعجل في بعض الشيء لانه الوقت قصير
دكتور محمد ابو رومان يعني ربما الظواهري
نفسه طويل ولكن في المقابل عندما يصدر
كلام من البغداد يقول ان لديه مؤاخذات
شرعيه ومنهجيه بمعنى ان الفرع يقوم الاصل
الى اي حد سيتحمل الى اي حد سينعكس هذا
على ما يجري ميد
في سوريا وايضا في
العراق يعني انا بتقديري سينعكس ميدانيا
بشكل واضح وكبير على سوريا وانا ربما اتفق
تماما مع الاستاذ العزيز منتصر الزيات في
انه رساله الظواهري كانت اكثر نعومه ولينا
اتجاه البغدادي وحاول حسم الخلاف بطريقه
وديه و في محاوله لتجنب ظهور الخلافات الى
الع ع لكن رد البغدادي لا رد غير مسبوق رد
قاسي لغه فيها تحدي لغه شرسه غ لاول مره
يتم الحديث بهذه الطريقه اعتقد انه هذه
تنبع عن تجذير الخلافات واستفحالها وليس
عن الوصول الى طريق تصالح حتى داخل جبهه
النصره اصبح هنالك تيار قريب
من دوله العراق الاسلاميه وبقي تيار محدود
مع الجولان والبعض حتى ذهب باتجاه احرار
الشام او الجبهه الاسلاميه لكن ربما ضرت
النافعه انا في تقديري انه مثل هذه
الخلافات والتي طغت على السطح وهذه
التباينات بين اجنده القاعده سواء كانت
دوله العراق الاسلاميه او القاعده
المركزيه وبين الفصائل الاخرى ل الثوره
السوريه ربما هذا يساعد على الفرز والفرز
في المرحله القادمه ضروري وضروري جدا من
اجل عدم التباس الثوره السوريه باجن
واولويات اخرى فهذا سينعكس سينعكس في
خلافات ربما ينعكس في اشتباكات في بعض بعض
الاماكن وقد ظهرت الخلافات واضحه عندما
اصدر احرار الشام رفضوا تشكيل دوله العراق
الاسلاميه في سوريا والعراق وهنالك عدد
كبير من العلماء ابو بصير الطرطوسي وغيرهم
هذه الخلافات بدات تبرز الى العلن ولكن
ربما بروز هذه الخلافات الى العلن قد يعني
يساعد كثيرا الثوره السوريه على تحديد
اجنتها واولويات والتميز عن القاعده اعود
اليك منتصر زياد ربما يساعد الثوره
السوريه هذا الفرز ولكن في النهايه ربما
ايضا ينع سلبا على القاعده نفسها بمعنى
انه ربما يستقطب زعماء تنظيم القاعده في
اماكن اخرى وخصوصا انه نسال يعني من هي
الجهه المخوله لحسم هذا الخلاف الحاصل
حاليا مع النفس الطويل الذي تتحدث
عنه اعتقد انه مجلس شورى
القاعده هو الذي يمكنه ان يحسم هذا
الخلاف انا لا اتشك في تاثيرات هذا الامر
سلبيا على الثوره في سوريا فاعتقد
انه اذا يعني الدرس الذي وعاه الجولاني
حينما وسعت القاعده من اهدافها في العراق
خسرت وتقريبا منذ عام 2011 او قبل ذلك
ايضا حينما طاشت ضربات القاعده في العراق
فقدت معها وغطاء سياسي كبير كد يمكنها من
العمل
الجولاني تفحص هذا وهو يعمل مع اطراف اخرى
او مع فصائل اخرى من اجل تحقيق ا اهداف
الثوره السوريه اعتقد ان هذا المعنى هو
الذي في النهايه
ا سيمضي وهذا يدفعني للسؤال ربما يعني كل
ممكن ان نرى الجزء المليء من الكاس وربما
ننظر بطريقه اخرى هل تراها بدايه النهايه
بالنسبه للقاعده دكتور محمد ابو
رمان يعني انا بتقديري انه هذه مرحله
جديده من مراحل القاعده تكشف عن انعكاس
التحولات التي حدثت في القاعده الفتره
الاخيره مقتل اسامه بن لادن غياب قيادات
كارزميه التحول الى رساله لامركزيه لكن
دعيني اتفق سريعا مع الاستاذ منتصر الزياد
في انه ابو محمد الجوراني حاول تجنيب ال
جبهه النصره هذا السيناريو سيناريو
الاخطاء الكارثيه التي وقعت فيها قاعده
العراق والتي اراد ابو البغدادي ان يمتد
بها من العراق الى سوريا لكن من الواضح
انه جزء رئيسي من جبهه النصره حازه
للبغدادي وبالتالي هذا سينعكس على داخل
القاعده نفسها في سوريا وعلى علاقتها
بالفصائل المسلحه الاخرى ايضا ربما نفس
السؤال اختم به معك منتصر الزيات انت كيف
ترى تاثير ما حدث بشكل عام على القاعده
هل هل يمكن فعلا اعود للسؤال هل يمكن ان
يستقطب اخرين داخل
[موسيقى]
القاعده اذا اذا اذا لم يستطع الدكتور
ايمن الظواهري ان يحتوي هذا الموقف
بطريقته
في المفاوضات وهو ذكي جدا اعتقد انه
مستقبل القاعده هيتاثر
وبالتالي تصد الجيوب الاقليميه او هذا هذا
الحدث اذا اذا مضى الى نهايته ولم يستطع
الدكتور ايم ظاهري ومن معه احتواء هذا
الموقف اعتقد انه الامتدادات الاقليميه
التي هي في حقيقه الامر ليست بناء تنظيمي
على النحو الذي كان معروفا القاعده اعتقد
انه سيته دد طيب اشرت الى مجلس الشورى
يعني هل هناك شيء اخر يمكن ان يفعله
الظواهر في هذه المرحله
لتلافى المزيد من الاضرار بالقاعده في هذه
المرحله
انا يعني اتصور ان الدكتور الزواري هو
المرجعيه الباقيه يعني بعد الدكتور بعد
الشيخ اسامه بن لاد رحمه الله عليه
الدكتور ايمن ظهري له مرجعيه صحيح كلام
البغدادي
قاسي ولم يكن منظورا او متوقعا لكن تبقى
مرجعيه الظواهري على المحك هنا انا
اراهن يمكن معلوماتي قديمه لكن انا اراهن
على ان الدكتور ايمن ظاهري بقدراته
الخططيه الحركيه التنظيميه ا قادر على انه
يحتوي هذا التصدع لانه ان استمر هيكون
هيمثل
متغير نوعي جديد قد يؤدي الى نهايه هذه
الاسطوره
التي بداها اسامه بن لادن
بضد الاستعمار العالمي شكرا منتصر الزيات
المحامي والخبير في شؤون الجماعات
الاسلاميه شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا جزيلا
للدكتور محمد ابو رمان من عمان الباحث في
مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه في الجامعه
الاردنيه وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر فيما
[موسيقى]
الله
h